if the world was ending and you could
save
only6 images as the final record of
planet Earth what kind of moments would
you
preserve this is an actual question NASA
faced in
1977 when they decided to attach to the
Voyager spacecraft's golden records
encoded with a selection of photos
intended to immortalize life on our
fragile plan
planet and when I look at these pictures
which have now left our solar system and
are hurdling out into the cosmic dark I
can't get out of my head how they will
probably one day be all that's left of
us in the vacuum of space these images
could last for billions of years
outliving the Earth outliving the Sun
and though that should maybe be
comforting I think it scares
me
[Music]
space has long been a birthplace of
existential dread early astronaut
programs were haunted by concerns of
space Madness the theory that humans
would be mentally and spiritually broken
by entering the celestial Abyss it makes
sense space is a death trap without a
space the very blood in your veins would
form bubbles that block circulation the
neurons in your brain exploding with
pain until lack of oxygen causes you to
pass out with death arriving just 90
seconds later even a successful Voyage
involves a prolonged period and cramped
seclusion surrounded by the Hostile dark
though space Madness is no longer an
official term anxiety mood swings and
severe emotional distress have all been
documented in those who have touched the
void the idea that a human mind plunged
into the infinite sea of space might you
know drown has crept into the
foundations of how we depict the cosmos
in 2001 A Space Odyssey The Narrative
begins in the shallows depicting a clean
orderly future of space travel that
would have been comforting to its late
60s audience yet in both the film and
the novel these early space scenes are a
facade a veneer of fathom ability
concealing the gaping ma of the
unfathomable the deeper you descend into
the story The clearer it becomes that
all the artificial gravity and neatly
divided meals amount to a feudal attempt
to give order to a chaotic Universe like
space itself 2001 ultimately proves
immense and impenetrable feeling like
something the Mind wasn't meant to fully
Encompass a Counterpoint to this
vastness exists in Andre tar sk's film
Solaris the story of a psychologist sent
to a research station where all crew
members have become trapped within their
own memories solarus is technically
another tale of spaceborn Madness yet
while 2001 spans from the dawn of
humanity to a nebulous future stage of
evolution the scale of Solaris is
intensely personal despite primarily
taking place in Space the film like the
characters constantly flashes back to
small all intimate moments on Earth far
from a story of Humanity's Ascension
Solaris makes the case that the
maddening power of space has less to do
with the Stars and more to do with the
trauma we carry with us into the dark
like preserved photographs the past
lingers both a steadying anchor and a
crushing
weight in the face of a vast indifferent
Universe how do we decide what moments
to hold on to the game outer Wilds
forces you to confront this question
over and over and over again you play as
an alien exploring the cosmos in a
worryingly lowtech spaceship and the
main thing you do in outer Wilds is well
Die the game is a crash course in why
space is so nightmarish but every
failure is an opportunity to learn from
your mistakes because spoiler alert for
the first 22 minutes of the game game
every time you perish you're sent
backwards to the start of a Time
loop it's a mechanic that changes the
value of each moment though I remained
cautious for my first few Loops I soon
began to throw myself into the void
without care all my fears of space Blown
Away simultaneously I began to skip over
smaller moments why waste time roasting
a marshmallow or speaking with a friend
if all this is going to be reset anyway
yet at the end of each life outer Wilds
displays images depicting all you've
accomplished your very own golden record
it's a feature that subtly reframes what
experiences are significant watching the
sunrise might not get you any closer to
beating the game but when your life
literally flashes before your eyes it's
the moment that stands
out yet there's this other moment that
stands out lat into the game I became
separated from my ship I wasn't too
nervous at first I knew I could
definitely catch up with oh wow that's
really moving caught in the gravity of a
planet my ship faded further and further
out of view soon it was hopeless and as
I looked out across Oblivion I realized
this Loop wasn't going to end until I
ran out of oxygen and though I knew I'd
wake back up where I started the thought
of drifting until then waiting for my
inevitable eyes made me feel well it
reminded me of a historical fragment I'd
learned long ago the first living thing
to orbit the Earth was a dog named Leica
part of a Soviet experiment to discover
the harmful effects of space on a body
like his journey through the Stars was
designed to be strictly One Way sent to
space on board a tiny metal coffin it
was assumed she' die in space from
running out of oxygen instead the craft
overheated the last words she likely
ever heard was a biologist saying please
forgive
us my ill- fad drift through the cosmos
didn't end when I ran out of oxygen
either instead my body slowly fell into
the Sun the voyage concluding in
premature flames of course unlike Leica
my journey then continued although the
unsettling experience stayed with me on
board her doomed craft leica's heart
rate accelerated to three times its
usual rate she was terrified did she
also feel betrayed I wonder did she
understand enough of what was happening
to feel betrayed there's a photo of a
dog on the golden record meant to
commemorate the Loyalty of our canine
friends please forgive us
Leica should she forgive
us the trajectory of this ship is
unchanging
in Douglas trumble's Silent Running a
vessel is on an unalterable path towards
annihilation in CLA Dennis's High Life a
annihilation in Cecil Richards under a
star called Sun a vessel is on a you get
it as a piece of interactive fiction
under a star called sun stands out from
the two films telling through pixel art
and short Snippets of text the story of
a lone cosmin not whose ship is drifting
into the sun yet despite their hopeless
status the Explorer continues to care
for the plants on board their condemned
vessel it's a ritual the protagonists of
all three pieces of media take part in
for different reasons in Silent Running
the plants are the last specimens of
vegetation from a Barren Earth a final
record of green that must be preserved
in high life the plants are the sole
source of food for the main character
and his infant child a matter of
survival yet none of these characters is
going to survive for very long though
they continue to obsess over their
plants Health maintaining routines even
knowing the end is coming I check on the
plants in the greenhouse I check for
bugs I check the moisture of the soil I
check the dust on the leaves and when no
one is around I hum to
them like the crew in soluris the
astronaut in a star called sun is
trapped in their Memories the ship's
interior sometimes distorting into a
street corner from their past memories
invade the film high life with similar
abruptness vignettes from the main
character's childhood coming and going
without context it seems reflective of
how the protagonist child Only Knows
Earth from fragmented images on the
ship's corrupted hard
drive instead of a sun the ship in high
life is headed towards a black hole
and yet the main character continues to
raise his child to give her whatever
life he can no matter how short despite
the looming Cosmic Destruction the film
argues these moments matter these
memories hold weight I wish I had made
more of an effort to remember the
protagonist says at the end of a star
called Sun I wish I had taken more
[Music]
photos in addition to images encoded on
the golden record is the Japanese
romantic Melody Pusa wara translating to
kinds of flowers I think there's
something inspiring about this song
traveling on in defiance of the cosmos
billions of kilometers from the nearest
flower there's also something profoundly
unsettling about it because on an
Interstellar scale Voyager 1 has gotten
nowhere even the closest star is
trillions of miles further away space is
so much emptier than we realize when we
think of the planets our mind goes to
the model from classrooms that has them
all in a neat row but space doesn't look
like this it doesn't even look like this
that's still way too close together it
looks like this that tiny pale blue dot
beneath Saturn's rings that's the Earth
and everything in space is constantly
moving hurdling through the dark at
break neck speeds we like to think of
that Darkness as something loud
something that ships can audibly whoosh
through but without air molecules to
vibrate the vacuum of space is silent
there are no explosions either at least
not the fiery type from Sci-Fi movies a
real space battle would be dead quiet
punctuated only with the occasional
burst of heat that would quickly implode
how is anyone supposed to navigate this
vast silent alien
sea in our ongoing search for
extraterrestrial life we've turned to
radio waves to make noise in the cosmos
some of these signals have traveled as
far out as 300 trillion kilm want to see
that on a map here it is sorry I'll zoom
in maybe once more there that's the area
our messages have reached it's another
pale blue dot and it's probably an
exaggeration because most of our signals
which are primarily a jumble of old TV
and in radio dramas likely Fall Apart
after that many light years the memories
blurring into meaningless
static in the game the anglerfish
project it is your job to sort through
the static you play as an old man
working for a mysterious company in the
far reaches of space using a probe
attached to an actual fishing pole to
catch and document Wayward signals from
Earth most are a jumble of nonsense old
advertisements and PS days but sometimes
you'll reel in a love letter or a
fragment of History it's a lonely
isolating experience that encourages you
to reflect on the types of messages
we've blasted into the void it made me
wonder what an alien intelligence would
even make of
erritis Beyond being time capsules the
golden records are also designed to be
messages informing aliens of our planet
after all the Voyager probes won't
dissip at like radio waves though
they're much slower if by some miracle
an alien found and decoded the record
they' discover along with images and
music sounds of Earth including
chimpanze
noises I'm not entirely sure an alien
would understand the intent behind that
one I'm not entirely sure I do but what
if right what if these records made
contact what if extraterrestrials under
stood their contents and traced the
craft back to
Earth if I'm being honest the scariest
moment of the outer Wilds probably
wasn't that time I fell into the Sun but
when I descended into a fog in the
center of a planet and saw are those
Stars they were in fact the lights of
giant alien anglerfish and unfortunately
they noticed
Me Maybe we don't don't want aliens to
hear us the Dark Forest hypothesis is
the theory that the reason space seems
so devoid of life is because any species
that makes too much noise is
extinguished by hostile extraterrestrial
life science fiction has long told
stories of humans alerting something to
our presence we should have left alone
in some horror fiction these aliens roll
up to our home planet bringing the
destruction directly to us but I think
the scarier incarnation of horror alien
is one encountered in the far reaches of
space the aliens in these stories often
feel like personifications of the
unknown itself a punishment for our
blind hubristic push into the Beyond
it's not just the aliens that make the
edge of space horror genre frightening
it's the
isolation Okay having said that we now
obviously have to talk about the game
Alien in isolation based on the iconic
film franchise this game has you explore
an empty ship empty except for of course
the alien there's a Litany of techniques
the game uses to make this creature
scary there's the fact your weapon
barely works the fact it can move
through vents the fact that your only
way of tracking it is with this tiny
analog screen that forces you to glance
away from what's in front of you but the
most effective technique of all has
nothing to do with the creature and
everything to do with the
setting an effective horror genre space
station is basically a haunted house
though lacking in cobwebs and creaking
floors it is a place of dim corridors
concealing monsters one that sequesters
its characters from any hope of rescue
the cosmos beyond the station can be
seen as part of the structure with space
itself a single enormous horror set
piece a setting so frightening you
almost don't need the
alien is a space filled with hostile
life scarier than a space that's empty
Arthur C Clark author of 2001 A Space
Odyssey famously stated two
possibilities exist either we are alone
in the universe or we are not both are
equally
terrifying here on Earth we are perhaps
the most sheltered Children of the
universe solar wind from our sun Shields
us from Interstellar radiation creating
an island of safety in the roaling
cosmic ocean Jupiter defends Earth from
asteroids like a protective older
sibling with its gravitational pull
Earth's magnetic field extends tens of
thousands of kilometers into space
safeguarding the surface from deadly
charged particles Mars and Venus didn't
get magnetospheres at
all it's difficult to convey just how
inhospitable the other planets in our
solar system are Jupiter's Great Red
Spot that little dot on the planet
surface is a storm larger than the Earth
itself if you were to descend into this
melstrom temperatures would rise to over
1300° C around
2,400 de F not even the cracked
yellowing surface of Venus otherwise the
hottest planet in our solar system gets
that
scorching on the opposite side of the
spectrum the outer ice giants Uranus and
Neptune spin so far from the warmth of
the sun their atmospheres regularly fall
hundreds of degrees below
freezing beyond our solar system there
are likely billions of exoplanets in our
galaxy alone although we've only managed
to spot around 5,000 but given the sheer
number of potential earthlike worlds it
seems that there has to be some other
form of life out there but maybe that's
a privileged Earth
perspective it seems like other beings
must exist because well we exist but
until we know more about the origin of
life it's challenging to calculate just
how lucky we are to be
here because we've had it so relatively
easy space hasn't always been a source
of fear in the past some cultures
assumed it was a flat backdrop a shallow
Dome of tiny lights surrounding a globe
that sits in the center of the universe
even as our understanding grew and the
scale of the solar system became more
and more apparent many assumed we'd find
other habitable worlds right next door
in the late 19th and early 20th century
the idea that Mars or the moon might be
full of undiscovered life didn't seem so
far-fetched when your only frame of
reference is the lushness of Earth space
seems like it would be jam-packed with
extraterrestrials the once a distant
dream space travel was also once
portrayed more flippantly in Jules
Vern's 19th century novel from Earth to
the Moon the lead characters make it to
the Moon by shooting their vessel out of
a giant Cannon because why not it was
difficult to imagine the true nature of
space a place where without gravity your
bones rapidly lose density a place where
the lack of days and nights create
insomnia a place of silent inhospitable
lifelessness
perhaps the closest thing to True space
Madness manifested during the 1976
Soviet Mission soyu 21 the operation was
supposed to be routine involving a
60-day stay on board the salute 5 space
station but just a few weeks in the crew
claimed a maddening odor had filled the
cabin a smell so toxic and persistent
the operation had to be called off yet
allegedly upon the the reserve crew's
arrival no unusual smell or fume leakage
was detected the scent was likely an
intense delusion a nightmare born from
the claustrophobic conditions mixed with
the psychological Terror of the cosmic
vastness perhaps it's better to remain
on the
ground but even in Earth's protective
Embrace we are not completely safe from
the cosmos asteroids hurled from the
Beyond aren't just the stuff of disaster
movies space rocks large enough to
trigger mass extinctions have struck our
planet in the past wiping out far
greater dynasties of life than Humanity
even with Jupiter looking out for us the
Earth has close calls all the time and
even if we aren't on an eventual
Collision Course with an apocalyptic
asteroid we are on a collision course
with the Sun a few billion years from
now our sun will become a red giant and
in all likelihood swallow the Earth and
even if if we don't end in fire the sun
like all stars in the universe is
eventually going to
die in
1816 many people became terrified that
the sun's death was imminent telescopes
discovered massive sun spots growing
like mold upon the solar surface and
temperatures began to drop this event
called the year without summer saw then
unprecedented snowfall in the northern
hemisphere in the resulting chaos the
somewhat Infamous Lord Byron was
inspired to craft an apocalyptic eulogy
simply titled
Darkness I had a dream which was not all
a dream the bright Sun was extinguished
and the stars did wander darkling in the
Eternal space rayless and pathless and
the icy Earth swung blind and blackening
in the moonless air of course the sun
did not go out in 1816 the sunspots
actually had nothing to do with the
falling temperatures the Winter's true
origin was the eruption of the Mount
Tambora Strat volcano in the Pacific
which blanketed the globe in volcanic
gas though this shroud eventually lifted
I see it as a reminder of how fragile
Earth's atmosphere is of how little
change it would take to make our planet
just another Barren
Rock perhaps impermanence is the true
most frightening aspect of the cosmos
even our galaxy won't endure forever in
roughly 4.5 billion years the Milky Way
will collide with the Andromeda galaxy
the galactic fender bender flinging
Untold stars out into the void if
nothing lasts if everything in the
universe ourselves included is on an
unchangeable arc towards Annihilation
Why Try to preserve anything at all what
meaning could a single image a memory a
life possibly have
maybe permanence isn't what gives
something value yes every plant is going
to wilt every radio signal is going to
Decay every marshmallow is going to burn
or be digested on a cosmic scale the
golden record probably isn't going to
get very far so what on a personal level
things that have been lost still matter
moments still linger the night sky can
still move us even with the knowledge
that one day every light will go out and
there will be no one left to witness the
darkness the trajectory of this ship is
unchanging I'm still going to water the
plants and hey as always thank you for
watching if you enjoyed this video and
want to support the channel consider
liking subscribing and hitting the
notification icon to stay up to date on
all things curious see you in the next
video
for